hey guys what's going on welcome to
another video this video is just gonna
be a quick fYI video so to speak up
until now I've always used VLC media
player to stream stuff from the
Raspberry Pi camera module to another
computer or whatever and actually I
found a better solution to that and that
is with this here let me bring up the
topic I found this topic on the
Raspberry Pi forums I'll put a link to
it in the description just thought I'd
try it out
seemed it was getting kind of good good
reviews in the posts and stuff so I
tried it out and this what happens is
this and so I'll show you guys here I'm
now moving the camera and I'm like
waving over the camera so you can see
that the you know before the latency
with even VLC was sometimes like two
three four seconds like really bad this
latency is darn near instant so I don't
really notice any problems with it and
in fact maybe I can show you guys to
this way so there's a screen and there's
my camera anyway it's a very good very
good thing it's got its using motion
JPEG and before I had used in and its
really MJPEG right and it's called
motion JPEG not to be confused with the
motion module with with the raspberry
PI's camera module and all that but
motion does use also M JPEG but anyway
um so I'm real happy with it and also
just in case you didn't see the what
I've been using is this little camera
box I got it from MCM electronics let's
see if I can bring that up yeah here we
go it's this camera box if you upper
link to this as well in the description
there's the camera box and then you also
have to get the the wall mount if you
want it so that this is just the camera
box here and then the wall mount is what
attaches to it and then you put this on
the wall so this is missing one of the
pieces because it's on my wall but you
basically just slide it onto your wall
and it's mounted so that's the idea
there the camera case is simple enough
it didn't come with any instructions but
there are instructions online for like
how to put this thing
together so I just used those um so
that's that also just in case anybody is
curious what I have this plugged into it
is this Jack berry
I don't know power supply it's portable
power supply just for the record I'm not
paid to mention either of these things
and funny enough I actually got both of
these based on advertisements online the
Jack berry thing came from like a
Twitter ad and I was like wow that's a
lot of power and it's 12,000 milliamps
and it powers my pie accidentally left
it plugged in it honestly powers the pie
for like a day and a half full of Apple
off of a full charge
um and then so I got that off an ad and
then also I got this camera case off of
just like a Google Adsense ad um so I'm
actually pretty happy it made me happy
just to know that Adsense is hopefully
getting a little better so a lot of
times I get ads that don't even apply to
me I totally understand why people block
them but I don't use any adblock or
anything like that so anyway I got this
and because before I had this was like
honestly like one of the smallest camera
cases I could find I mean this thing is
like a foot by 6 inches by 6 is horrible
and my wife had actually given me
clearance to put this up on her house
but we both were kind of mad about it so
I decided not to and anyway I kind of
given up until I got the Google Ad for
this so thanks google uh so anyway
that's that and then also it's the
edimax Wi-Fi adapter um the only thing I
would say is if you're gonna eat you
can't really house these outside you
could if you have like a fan so one of
the things I found what I was looking
for camera casing is that a lot of
camera cases come with a fan and a
heater and I was like do they really
really a fan in here for a camera like
I've used cameras outside before it's
not that big of a deal I mean they get
hot but it's like whatever and but yeah
you definitely need it um at least with
the Raspberry Pi what went first was the
edimax Wi-Fi adapter like right now if I
touch the Wi-Fi adapter it's hot it's
probably like a hundred degrees or
something right now and like my room is
like 70 degrees
that's Fahrenheit by the way um where
and like you put that thing outside and
it just it's done so I live in Texas
it's so even though it's you know late
September right now it gets really hot
and I had it outside on like a few like
90 degrees days and it's still
overheated and even like in the morning
it would overheat when it's like 70
something so anyway not really um the
best for being outside you definitely
need it to be like inside where the
ambient temperature is acceptable
um but you can put it in like windows
I've been putting mine like in the top
part of my window facing out and like
that works really well so anyway that's
that um I don't really have too much
else to add about this I do have a few
more exciting Raspberry Pi updates for
you guys I've been having a lot of fun I
just put one in my car and also got a
screen for my Raspberry Pi really cheap
too I'm really surprised at how cheap
you can get screens it has to be RCA but
whatever so anyway um stay tuned for
those videos also got flash videos
coming out already out now um so anyway
stay tuned for that if you guys have any
questions or comments about this if I
left something out or you're confused
about something or if I forget to post a
link or whatever let me know no sense in
doing a tutorial on this just because
this right here you just type it in this
code here let's go here and this go here
restart your PI and you're all set so
there's really no reason for me to do a
tutorial on it I'm just mostly a letting
y'all know that this exists and it's
probably the best one so for also
obviously I mean this is just a simple
HTML if you wanted to edit this for
yourself you totally can edit it you can
make the HTML page do whatever the the
actual quality again of the preview is
it's pretty good I mean the quality is
nice but this is actually a dumbed down
version because it's just a preview but
I mean we could put this like over here
and we can snap a photo so it's just
like click on record image here so it
takes the image we'd go here to look at
them so we look at this image this is
like the preview of the image but this
is the full size image so I mean you can
take full sized images and also the
video is full sized also if you are
using it as a security camera you can
turn on motion detection so what that's
going to do is it's
going to detect if there's motion and if
there is it will start recording so I
gotta put my hand here and hopefully
it's making a recording sometimes it's
not the best like I've had a few times
where it didn't actually record anything
but let's see if it recorded anything
here not seen it video see censor region
I think it's recording I was able to get
it to do it at one point but anyway I'll
just record a video for now you might
have to mess with the sensor and stuff
but anyway that's like the video we can
stop that recording it's going to
process it probably for a minute we'll
go to the videos here's our video and
there we have our actual video then you
can also download the video see if it's
done now that up I'll bring it over here
so you can see that it is actually a
1080p video try to fit it on the screen
in time but about that it's anyway it
records decent video and you know to get
an actual camera to record high quality
video like this and be viewable via like
a browser or whatever is actually really
expensive so it's kind of neat to have a
Raspberry Pi
do this stuff for you but anyway that's
it with the Raspberry Pi and the new
idea for streaming video if you guys
have any question comment below as
always thanks for watching